[Music]
from accompany limping towards
bankruptcy the studio behind six bruce
willis movies in the last four years
Stanley's former business partner who he
has a restraining order against the guy
in the Paris Hilton the sex tape and E
from Entourage
comes a film that isn't the Godfather
movie we need but the Godfather movie we
deserve right now he was 12 years old he
didn't hammer on his prick uh Gotti
welcome to New York a city where
anything can happen
like the ghost of John Gotti telling you
his life story entire song about the
time he told his son his life story
remember what I used to tell you guys
that's full of other people telling John
Gotti's life story let me turn you about
your own man it's kind of like John
Gotti inception except the person who's
dreaming fell asleep watching Goodfellas
[Music]
[Applause]
good there was non Goodfellas enter a
soulless mob purgatory that fails to me
even the baseline requirements of
storytelling but a forget about it
because who needs a clear hero a message
any insight into how the mob really
worked or a coherent plot when you've
got access that would make my cousin
Vinnie blush it's either me or dent the
killing us that's nothing for the bar
and anyone else was in the car with him
and a Mexican who units you've got a lot
of thinking to do these are the large
you gotta live with the musical stylings
of pitbull and a rapid fire parade of
generic mobster names throughout the
entire film gasp at Castle Hill piney
Frank and Sammy bull ready to veto any
can best Cuccia Colombo's the bonanno's
Willie boy Bobby Borriello Vincent to
chinju don t make this boobies got more
names than Pauly endings Delvecchio you
know him right he's friends with Joey
the trout in swamp ass Baca Laurie oh by
the cacciatore brother's place so who
are you going to believe the
professional critics behind their little
keyboards who gave it a combined 0
percent on Rotten Tomatoes or all the
real fans who signed up for a Rotten
Tomatoes account the month the movie
came out only let reviews for the two
films produced by movie pass and never
post it again huh
it got a hit story it's me got the all
young John Gotti junior old John Gotti
junior I could watch a cage for hours I
got yous babe the menu at an Olive
Garden the Caesar salad us to die for
they'd use a tuna sandwich with some
pizzas spaghetti meatballs or
something's got the shrimp in there Ming
you like this the best line Joe Pesci
never got to say apakah bust up your ass
sideways
what movie pass
only if we have the support of all five
boroughs Queens Brooklyn Manhattan
Staten Island the Bronx
why would one New York mobster remind
another New York mobster with the fiber
rows of New York are unless you thought
you could steal from another Scorsese
movie without us noticing each of the
five points is a finger when I close my
hand it becomes a first got'em slide to
the left slide to the right reverse
reverse reverse reverse cha cha now
y'all there is no epic voice guy only
Zuul don't spell part a backwards
because it's a tribe zendaya is beachy